[Music]
[Applause]
take another look our ford home run
replay that is a fastball
and it's a fastball down and jose really
likes fastballs down
as he just showed ari hara
just passed a milestone he came in with
1
999 total bases
now 2003.
[Applause]
david dahl now four outs recorded by
kopeck all of them
strikeouts oh that ball
hit pretty well out to right field eaton
goes back looks up it's gone
and so dawg gets the rangers on the
board with one swing
it's two to one michael kopeck has been
very stingy with the hit so far
this season had not allowed a home run
in fact only three hits coming into this
game in 10 and two thirds
and this looked like a little slider
that wasn't particularly sharp the
slutter has looked good today this one
though
not so much and down and into a lefty as
we know
can be the nitro zone and david dahl
taking advantage
of the slider down and in
fifth home run of the series for the
rangers
madrigal lines and that'll get down
he's going to try for second and he's
going to make it
when you're going well and nick is going
well
everything finds a place to land safer
and a very good right fielder has a
problem with this nick runs it into a
two base hit
that is gonna get to the wall madrigal
will score
anderson's got a double and an
eight-game hitting streak
rangers outfield has been fairly shallow
all the way around this entire series so
there's a splitter that doesn't split
tim goes down and hits the daylights out
of it and no chance for doll in left
field
[Applause]
all the way to the wall he's going to
try for three as anderson scores
it's a triple
[Applause]
this time he's rewarded
that's 17 runs driven in and a good
advantage
by adam i mean he battled finally got
something to his liking
and shifting around toward left center
when you throw breaking balls most
likely a hitter is going to pull it
that's what they did away from the shift
and the hit parade continues
eaton twice has led the american league
in triples
that's number 45 in his career
get it done gallo will make the grab
here comes eaton it's five to one
this could get in there and it will
for garcia so two on nobody out
muscles this one out in the left center
it's gonna score two runs
he's trying for a triple and he stands
at third
[Applause]
driving in runs seven and eight he gets
a fastball he's looking fastball
and he hits it with authority
pretty interesting last year only 29
games but he had three extra base hits
they were doubles and right now he's got
three doubles and two triples
in field in eaton bunts madrigal gonna
hold
now he tries to score and he will easily
cross the plate
that was a good piece of base running by
nikki
that could put him over the top he got
him looking
kopeck's got nine strikeouts i mean
i think michael's starting to lose it
he's allowed two people to hit it
ten strikeouts career mark
[Applause]
in the meantime we can be living with
cleveland
they'll get one there you go
kopeck gets through five michael kopech
was brilliant today
he had six strikeouts through two
ten through four
and in the fifth they got a double play
ball to get those
big 14 and 14th and 15th outs and right
now he's the pitcher of
record in this one that wasn't the
intent but when he got there knocking at
the door tony allowed him to go through
that fifth inning
i don't think we see them until as early
as
june yeah that's wow june they come
to arlington in late june june 21st
that should be pulled off by then blind
drive to shortstop and
kind of phileppa showing off his hops
and it's a one two three bottom of the
fifth sixth inning coming up rangers
offense
needs to get going
three straight singles rangers go
station to station
and the bases are loaded with nobody out
this one hit out into left field another
base hit
and the rangers continue to go one link
at a time but that
drives in a run they're still loaded
nobody out and it's eight to two
you see his numbers they're pretty good
but don't expect him to
be in the game for a long time
bouncer left side could be a tough play
montana charges and he does
throw out garcia for the first down of
the inning but the rangers
get across another run it's eight to
three
[Applause]
high chopper back to the mound crochet
will turn
throw to first and not in time and the
rangers get to run
across great hustle by solac to beat
that one out
keep the inning going and put a run on
the board it's eight to four i think he
thought it was an automatic see the slow
turn
taking his time and that throw just
being a little bit offline and so
because of the reach as well
and the casualness of the throw that
allowed nick solak to just barely beat
it
the 02 a bouncer to madrigal
and the white sox have swept the rangers
the final score today white sox eight
rangers four the off day will feel good
after a fourth
consecutive win